are you sure yeah being a venture
first man to walk on the moon maybe
something we've chosen a job so
difficult requiring so many
technological developments we're gonna
have to start from scratch
only after we mastered these tasks do we
consider trying to land on the moon Neil
if his flight is successful you'll go
down in history what kind of thoughts do
you have about that planning on the
flight being successful
and that is a big mother it'll go up
like a half kiloton to a bomb if it
blows the vehicles not safe you need to
fail down here so we don't fail up there
this isn't just another trip Neil you're
not was going to work do you think
they're coming back
there are risks but we have every
intention of coming back somebody got a
Swiss Army knife Swiss Army knife you
kidding me here we go six five four
three
do you question whether the program's
worth the cost in money in unless you
down here and you look up and you don't
think about it too much but space
exploration changes your perception and
it allows us to see things that we
should have seen a long time ago we have
serious problems
we've got this under control you're a
bunch of boys you don't have anything
under control
you
you